hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well among the five
intellectual virtues that Aristotle
discusses in nicob McCann effects book 6
that is habits or dispositions of mind
of the rational part of the soul that
make us able to do things in
particularly excellent ways in this case
to arrive at truth we find one that the
Greek term for which is noose and we
translate it in a number of different
ways none of which are perfect
translations always need to be
contextualized a bit there's three eye
words that we typically use for it
intellect which really does work in some
respects but sometimes you know Arizona
is going to use this to describe the the
rational part of the soul or parts of
the rational part as well rather than
Cabot's taxes or activities of it
intelligence that's also pretty good but
but you know we often associate
intelligence with a kind of raw capacity
and we think of it in terms of
activities of the mind rather than what
this is intuition also misleading to
translate
intuition although is a little talked
about there are some reasons why people
sometimes prefer that that sometimes
people say intuitive intelligence
putting the two of them together another
translation for this is mind now all of
these are describing something and we
have to remember it is not the the soul
itself or the part of the soul the
intellectual part of the soul but rather
a you know builds up dynamic disposition
or habit within the soul that helps us a
ride at truth truth in terms of both the
theoretical activities of the mind and
else we're also going to see in terms of
the practical activities of the mind and
the given person so news is going to
play a very important role and what does
it actually do here's the the clue to it
news or intellect is what allows us to
grasp aarika which are first principles
in in greek and these play an incredibly
important role not only within
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics but also
within his flock as a whole and he
thinks that you know this is because
they play a very important role in our
practical than our theoretical
inferences arguments decisions lives
teaching all of that sort of stuff we
can't begin from nowhere when we're
engaged in some sort of reasoning or a
deliberative process we have to know
some starting points the question then
is where do we get these starting points
from now Aristotle taught yeah at some
points for example in this very book
about getting our starting points from
experience he says that metaphysics in
fact that's why kids can't study
metaphysics effectively they don't have
enough experience which that has to be
translated into something else that
ultimately provides these starting
points and leads to knowledge about
things you know the starting points for
mathematics can be just given as axioms
or there's there's other ways that we
can arrive at them the Aristotle things
that we have a certain capacity or
rather disposition a habit of mind that
truthfully leads us to first principles
we grasp them this is I think why some
people want to translate it as intuition
which can be sometimes a bit misleading
you know we often associate intuition
with something that's a feeling and we
say well I don't really have you know
some sort of cognitive reason for why
I'm doing something I can't reason it
out but I have a just a vague gut
feeling that could be similar in certain
respects to what air ourselves talking
about but this is a bit more illuminated
than just you know that bear sense of
intuition that we're discussing there so
it truthfully grasp the first principles
the ark why is that important well you
notice that I've got three other kinds
of intellectual virtue here they as
depend upon these starting ones if you
don't like I said if you don't have
starting points to begin with you can't
actually get anywhere scientific
knowledge is really quite powerful but
think of it sort of like a machine that
unless it's actually got the fuel going
in and the raw materials thing and it
can't do anything scientific knowledge
is another intellectual virtue a habit a
habit assay you know sort of structure
within the mind that allows one to
generate knowledge from first principles
once you get those first principles to
work with
now you can do all sorts of deductive
work with them and you know draw out all
sorts of other really cool conclusions
and make something up but you have to
have those those principles to begin
with already can't get the thing started
wisdom and we have another video
specifically on this wisdom is in fact a
composite Aristotle says of scientific
knowledge and intelligence or intellect
news because wisdom in its true sense
consists in the conclusions from the
first principles
I'm a grass for the first principles
itself so you can't integrate the first
principles about with knowledge if you
don't possess the first principles so
you have to inquire to them somehow and
that's what intellect provides us with
what about prudence practical wisdom it
plays a role with practical wisdom as
well and this is a very important point
because as as we saw in the beginning of
mechanic and ethics book 6 it looks much
more like Aristotle is associating
intellect solely with that higher
theoretical part of the rational part of
the human soul now with the lower the
you know deliberative or or calculating
or you know reasoning part practically
reasoning part that is concerned with
things that then actually change as it
turns out this is going to play a role
in the whole realm of the Prudential as
well because even the prudence has to
begin from some starting points as a
matter of fact prudence has been you
have to begin from even more starting
points it doesn't work the same way as a
scientific knowledge does where just
does deductive things but it has to
grasp what is you know the beginning
points in that the
the situation the practical situation is
looking at from which it can then start
reasoning out or deliberating what it
needs to do so it you know as Arizona is
going to say in deductive or scientific
reasoning it rests the first and
unchangeable definitions that's another
way of thinking of starting points it's
sort of definitions ahora in in Greek
for demonstrations or Appa Texas that
that's involved in scientific knowledge
when we're talking about the whole role
of prudence and starting points that it
provides there one of the things that's
a starting point is perception MySpace's
perception of particulars not really do
we need to have arcade principles
working and the virtues actually supply
those in larger spec but we also have to
grasp the particulars we have to say
what is what what is relevant in the
situations interestingly this notion of
perception doesn't just mean sense
perception it means something like
grasping what has been called the
ethical salience of things either by
Nancy Sherman or Deborah Acton Berg and
beautiful turn a phrase what does that
really mean we're grasping moral values
Aristotle says in politics that we
actually do get a perception of good in
the bath the right of the raw the ugly
and the beautiful that these are not
just a matter of speech you know saying
things are certain ways they're not just
purely mental they are out there to be
grasped as such and that was part of
what news seems to be doing he also
talks about it as grasping the minor
premise this has to do with practical
reasoning and the role of what we call
practical syllogism which is some people
do of another video about particularly
in relation to to books some of the
Nicomachean ethics the minor premise is
the one that allows you
to apply the major premise which is the
universal premise the minor premise has
to do with the particulars from so for
example all sweet things should be
tasted this is a sweet thing therefore I
should taste it this is a sweet thing is
the minor premise Aristotle thanks that
news or Intel intellect intelligence it
is in fact providing practical reasoning
with that that sort of basis so this is
a intellectual virtue that that you
could say straddles the whole of the
rational part of the soul for Aristotle
the part that's concerned with the
theoretical matters where wisdom and
scientific knowledge is concerned in the
part concerned with practical matters
where we see concerns of prudence and
art or skill and the a lot of other
things having to do with deliberation